all right i have another very
interesting topic
inflammation okay now inflammation is a
normal healing repair process but the
problem is when your body has chronic
inflammation all sorts of destruction
can occur and also an infection against
a virus or a bacteria or another
pathogen
it's our own body's reaction to that
pathogen that creates the damage in
other words it's our own immune
inflammatory condition that creates the
collateral damage that we should be
concerned about and understand
thoroughly in order to
counter all this damage i mean think
about a cytokine storm where you have
this
hyper inflammatory immune response in
your lungs and doctors will give you
prednisone which is a synthetic cortisol
to help
calm it down
but it's the excess amount of
inflammation that really creates the
this collateral damage and then you have
autoimmune diseases right
crohn's rheumatoid arthritis even
alopecia which is like patches of your
hair falling out is an autoimmune
disease
and the common theme for autoimmune
diseases is inflammation so if you can
get rid of inflammation you can get rid
of the complications and symptoms and
problems with that autoimmune disease
then you have old injuries where the
body then creates this inflammation that
then can persist chronically
over years creating all sorts of scar
tissue stiffness and i have firsthand
knowledge of that with my left elbow my
back with my ankles from all the massive
injuries that i've experienced
and out of all the drugs the top selling
drugs the number one worldwide selling
drug
is humera what is that drug for
inflammation and so a tremendous amount
of people on this planet
have too much inflammation now before i
get into the causes of inflammation i
want to touch on
a new
word that you may never heard before
it's called inflammatory oncotaxis now
what is that it's a phenomenon where
cancer tends to spread
into areas
of
mechanical injury to your body so we're
talking about old injuries where there
is inflammation and that can be from
many different things
you could have
food irritation to your colon where you
have this repetitive
inflammatory response in your colon
where the cancer spreads into
it could be in the lungs where you're a
chronic smoker where you had
inflammation it could be in the arteries
due to high levels of glucose because
you are on a high carb diet or it can
actually travel into breast tissue
because you had some type of
injury to your breast tissue i mean this
is an important data because this gives
us prediction on where we might get
cancer so that way we can do something
about it before we get cancer all right
let's start with number one the first
cause of inflammation
this is a lack of cortisol it's the main
anti-inflammatory hormone in the body
cortisol and so how would you get a lack
of cortisol
well guess what by having too much
cortisol too much cortisol just like too
much insulin creates cortisol resistance
and so you have the situation where you
actually have a lot of cortisol flowing
through your bloodstream because you're
under a lot of stress but it's not
effective it's not working so if you
look at
a condition like cushing syndrome where
you have high levels of cortisol
all the symptoms really relate to a
deficiency of cortisol that is because
the receptors become resistant when you
have high levels of that hormone flowing
through your bloodstream
same thing happens with diabetes
with diabetes you have high levels of
insulin because the glucose is high
but it doesn't work that's why the blood
sugars start going higher because
there's nothing there to push it down
insulin is supposed to lower the blood
sugar but if it's ineffective it's not
going to do that so any condition where
you have an itis whether it's bursitis
arthritis tendinitis usually involves
a lack of cortisol because you have too
much cortisol and that's creating the
resistance too much cortisol is very
toxic just as too much insulin so it's
it's just one way
your body tends to protect against
excess amounts of cortisol but in the
process
it gives you a lot of other symptoms now
just so you know the best thing for
anything related to
itis is vitamin d and i'm going to get
to some of the remedies
after i'm done with the causes but what
you should know is any condition
where you have a need of
prednisone or more cortisol because you
have inflammation
you can substitute that with vitamin d
and at least doses of 10 000 ius but
probably 20 or 30 or even 40 000 i use
to create the effect because vitamin d
is the best anti-inflammatory and it's
not really even a vitamin it's a hormone
which acts very similar to cortisol all
right the next cause of inflammation is
allergies okay
so you have the obvious food allergies
like you're allergic to dairy
now that could be casein the protein in
milk and so if you eat dairy it's going
to create a constant inflammatory
condition in your digestive system
what about gluten that's the protein in
wheat how many people are allergic to
gluten many many people and even if you
don't have an allergy to gluten you can
have a gluten sensitivity or dairy you
might have
lactose intolerance right you're not
tolerant to the milk sugar so all these
things can create inflammation and then
you have environmental allergies right
so you have i don't know let's say
you're allergic to ragweed or something
like that that's exposing your sinuses
or your throat or your lungs to this
environmental allergy and it's creating
an irritation and inflammation or what
about poison ivy if i come
i don't know 300 feet next to poison ivy
i'll start itching so i am deadly
allergic to poison ivy and i seem to get
it every single year and at this point i
can't take anything for it because it
doesn't work and then you have another
type of allergy where you're allergic to
your own tissues okay that's called
autoimmune and you might not look at it
like an allergy but it's really
an allergy to your own tissues where
your immune system is attacking itself
you developed antibodies against your
own tissue and that could be for any
tissue like hashimoto's which is an
allergy to your own thyroid
hormones you can have lupus where you
have this allergy to
certain connective tissue or you can
have ms where you have an allergy to
your own
myelin sheath in your brain myelin
sheath is the coding around the nervous
system and if you think about what is
the main treatment for autoimmune
humera is one of the medications but
they also use prednisone
because cortisol is a powerful
anti-inflammatory
cortisol has an immune suppressive
action it basically turns off the immune
system so it just turns it off so now
you don't have all these reactions the
problem is it comes to the package if
you have no immune system you're more
susceptible to having
viruses invade the body and all sorts of
things happening
that you kind of lose your immune army
and in that process without inflammation
without immune reactions it can give you
a whole series of additional problems
all right number three let's talk about
that you have either acute infections or
chronic infections
now
you know it's pretty simple to
understand you you get exposed to a
virus or or a bacteria and then your
immune system kicks in you have this
inflammatory reaction and then it goes
away but what happens when you get
chronic infections where the virus goes
into the body and it goes into a dormant
state and it keeps coming out
out of remission and then goes back in
the remission like epstein-barr virus
like lyme's disease
and there's many infections that lie
dormant waiting
for the right opportunity to come out
and kick you when you're down so these
latent
viruses tend to
come out during times of stress
and so stress is a trigger for this
infection that then will create
inflammation and so this just tells us
that we need to strengthen our immune
system and the way to protect ourselves
and prevent these viruses from coming
out
is just to stay super healthy and then
you're protected all right number four
gut inflammation so whether someone has
an ulcer
or gastritis
or irritable bowel syndrome or some
autoimmune disease there could be
several causes of this inflammation in
the gut mainly it's going to be foods
okay now that could be a food allergy
it could be just
inflammatory foods as in high omega-6
fatty acids like soy oil canola oil
cottonseed oil these oils are so
pervasive in our food supply and you're
going to be very susceptible to getting
ulcers and inflammation to gut and even
having a weak spot so cancer can
actually go into that area now what
about constipation well that's like auto
intoxication you have this this lack of
flow
of food being digested and everything's
getting backed up so that can actually
create some inflammation as well what
about antibiotics if you take an
antibiotics you wipe out your friendly
bacteria that's there to protect you and
reduce inflammation so if there's some
way that you lose your flora in your gut
that could be the cause of why you have
inflammation in your gut in fact when
that inflammation exists then it
develops scar tissue
in the colon and it can
affect your ability to absorb nutrients
and it can create leaky gut that then
leads to more allergies and autoimmune
diseases and a lot of other problems so
as a side note for any type of gut
inflammation going on
the best
food actually is cabbage cabbage has
unique things in it that are really good
for gut inflammation
and cabbage seems to be easy to digest
especially if it's in like a
fermented form like sauerkraut or like
kimchi things like that or even like
coleslaw or raw cabbage seems to be
very very beneficial for anyone with
gastritis with anyone with an ulcer with
anyone with inflammation in the gut
another really good thing is the
wheatgrass juice or wheatgrass juice
powder because the chlorophyll in there
with other additional phytonutrients is
very healing on the inside of your skin
internally whether it's in the throat
the stomach the small intestine or the
large bowel goes in there and it tends
to create a really cool effect and
what's ironic is
wheat has gluten but not wheatgrass
juice powder okay because they capture
it before the seed exists so there's no
gluten so it's very very healing but
then if you eat wheat it'll actually
destroy the intestines another really
good remedy for gut issues
is zinc
l-carnizine okay just remember that
because that's a good remedy for ulcers
gastritis
it's a good form of zinc
that is very very healing all right the
next cause of inflammation which is
probably the most common
is glucose or sugar yeah glucose and
sugar and the other foods that turn into
sugar like refined carbohydrates what it
does is it raises this glucose flowing
through your bloodstream and
this very thin layer
of cells which is one cell layer thick
in your arteries
becomes seriously damaged and you get
this inflammatory condition and then the
body heals with either a clot or
plaquing
in the combination of cholesterol
or protein or calcium so you have this
calcium buildup and then you get heart
problems and you get heart attacks and
strokes other than that you're perfectly
fine but when you lose the vascular
supply and even the capillary supply to
your eyes you have eye damage every
different problem with the eye like
retinopathy cataracts
macular degeneration and if you lose
capillary blood flow to the nerves you
get peripheral neuropathy so you have
just tingling and um weird feeling in
your feet and high glucose also creates
inflammation in your kidney
and in your brain other than that
doesn't pretty much attack anything else
well
actually it does but i'm just being
sarcastic now when you have high levels
of glucose
insulin goes up
and then remember we talked about
cortisol being resistant insulin becomes
resistant
and when you have insulin resistance
your body pumps up more insulin and you
get more inflammation so
having the standard high carb diet is
just creating a constant state of
inflammation
in many different parts of your body but
it's not only glucose that causes
insulin resistance
it is also frequent eating as in
snacking
when you every time you eat you trigger
insulin so if you're eating so so-called
healthy foods
and but you're eating a lot of snacks
through the day you're also going to
create the same situation so you need to
go on a low-carb diet and you definitely
need to do intermittent fasting very
very important we'll touch on that in a
bit now number six your own fat cells
okay uh can cause inflammation
because there's certain type of
pro-inflammatory uh molecules like
cytokines that can then create more
inflammation and then inflammation
itself
can create insulin resistance
interesting so we have this two-way
street where we have inflammation
creating insulin resistance and insulin
resistance can create inflammation it's
a it's a never-ending um nightmare all
right number seven old injuries
i've touched on that but old injuries
can put you in a state of stiffness
inflammation
chronically and so it's very very
important if you have old injuries and
you have like arthritis
to not also consume a lot of high
glucose or
any glucose you want to be in a low-carb
diet to keep your inflammation at a
minimum and there's other things you
want to do as well but if you have
arthritis
and inflammation because of old injuries
and you're still consuming carbs
um i don't care how much tumeric or
vitamin d
or
remedies that you take
it's not going to really work sometimes
i'll see people with really bad
arthritis and they're
just taking pills they're taking fish
oil and they're thinking that's going to
solve the problem when in fact it's not
going to even create a dent into their
problem and that is why i'm doing more
of a comprehensive approach to this
topic because it's so important now the
next problem is very interesting
it is where you have a problem in your
bile ducts the bile ducts are little
tubes that connect from your liver to
the
gallbladder or small intestine and if
you have too much sludge in these little
tubes or you have a stone like a
gallstone
that can create a lot of inflammation
usually on the right side of your body
suspect there could be something wrong
with the gallbladder
or usually it's going to be in the bile
duct
a little bit higher up and you might
have some sludge not even a stone
but a thickened
sludge
caused because you don't have enough
bile salts i can't tell you how many
times
i've had patients come in to my clinic
when i was in practice with this problem
it's very very common yet not many
people know about it and they're getting
all sorts of rehab treatments they're
taking thousands of vitamins and
it's not working
okay a real simple remedy
for that condition is to start taking
bile salts okay purify bile salts and
there's a lot to know about it i put a
link down below if you want more
information but another really good
thinning agent for that uh problem is
tut cup
and you can buy it online and you take
it on empty stomach and it thins the
bile
allows the flow of the sludge to go
through and magically all that pain goes
away all right number nine low vitamin d
directly i mean vitamin d is a very
powerful anti-inflammatory if you're low
in vitamin d like the majority of the
population is
you're more susceptible for inflammation
and pain okay especially in your lower
back but it could be anywhere in your
bones in your joints in your knees in
your neck and so don't forget a vitamin
d deficiency as one cause of
inflammation this is why vitamin d can
help you prevent
cancer why because it gets rid of
inflammation and if someone had cancer
and they're in remission
the cancer can be reactivated
by
inflammation okay so remember that
because you want to have a goal of just
getting rid of inflammation
everywhere in your body that would be a
very very good survival goal all right
number 10 high levels of omega-6 fatty
acids and low levels of omega-3 fatty
acids so any foods with high omega-3
fatty acids like fish
cod liver oil or cod liver or fatty fish
like salmon
or sardines really really good to keep
your inflammation on the lower side
some people that start fasting
may develop inflammation because they're
not consuming any omega-3 fatty acids so
anytime you're doing
prolonged fasting i always recommend
taking the electrolytes b vitamins but
also omega-3 fatty acids because i've
observed people getting arthritis when
they're fasting and they think it's a
side effect from fasting but really it's
just a side effect because you have no
omega-3 fatty acids omega-3 fatty acids
are essential fatty acids what does that
mean essential it means that your body
needs them and you can't make them so
you need to get them from the diet and
without them you're going to have
problems and also on top of that
another compounding problem is we have
way too much omega-6 fatty acids and
that's all the vegetable oils which are
really seed oils
grain oils
really really bad but it's in our food
supply it's definitely in any fast food
restaurant you go to
or a lot of just regular restaurants
they'll put so much soy oil and corn oil
in their cooking uh whether it's eggs or
something deep fried or whatever so i
always when i go to a restaurant
i'll ask
the chef like what type of oil do you
use and you'd be shocked to find out if
you're going to be something like soy
oil i will just not eat foods that are
cooked with soy oil
and also start reading your ingredients
like in your
dressings right
if it says anything with soy oil canola
oil cottonseed oil i would avoid it even
if it's organic okay your salad dressing
should be olive oil and vinaigrette
something like that or avocado oil all
right then we have environmental toxins
like plastics in the environment
silicone breast implants could be a
source of inflammation and the thousands
of other chemicals that we are bathed in
on a regular basis now i want to mention
number 12 a second time because it's
very very important it's not only the
glucose that stimulates inflammation
it's the frequent eating because of the
high levels of insulin so one of the
most important things you can do on top
of everything else if you have
inflammation is go low carb okay but
really do the healthy version of keto
because that way you're adding in more
nutrients you're not just focusing on
low carb you're focusing on
high quality foods that also give you
additional health benefits like really
really great cruciferous vegetables and
large amounts of salad which have
phytonutrients that are
very very um anti-inflammatory with
loads of antioxidants because when you
have inflammation you're getting a lot
of free radical damage so you want the
antioxidants from the food as well as
you want the antioxidants from your own
body your body makes endogenous
antioxidants i'm talking like
antioxidant networks and one of the big
stimulants for that is fasting and one
of the things that just crushes and
destroys these antioxidants is frequent
eating so fasting is really key for
inflammation all right number 13 too
much iron okay
now iron um is
a mineral it's a trace mineral
that you don't need in large amounts and
our bodies don't have mechanisms to get
rid of iron
when you get an infection
both the good
bacteria and the pathogens
um compete for this iron apparently they
they eat iron and so our bodies have
this interesting mechanism
to bind up iron during infections
and this is why
people have a
higher incidence of getting anemia
when they have
infections and if you're deficient in
iron going into an infection
and then you're coming out of an
infection and you're fatigued and you
have anemia it could mean that you need
more iron and that's just a side note
but some people that have like a post
covid fatigue sometimes they need some
iron but typically you don't want to
overdo it with iron because too much
iron in your liver can create cirrhosis
and create a lot of inflammation
and a lot of scar tissue and fibrosis in
the liver but iron in general in large
amounts can create inflammation all
right now that you know all the causes
of inflammation
let's talk about what to do
number one the most important thing is
have enough vitamin d at least 10 000 i
use but if it's a chronic problem take
more take 20 30 even 40 000 ius um if
you're concerned about any toxicity i
put a video down below you should watch
that anytime you take vitamin d3 though
you also need k2 at the same time
especially if you're taking on a regular
basis because vitamin k2 helps prevent
the calcium buildup in the arteries so
k2 drives calcium
from the blood and the joints back into
the bone
so if people are concerned with the side
effect of vitamin d toxicity which is
hypercalcemia because the calcium builds
up in the arteries well guess what k2
handles that it protects you against
this excess calcium so they both work
together so realize the ratios
are 10 000 international units of
vitamin d3
to 100 micrograms not milligrams of k2
okay so that's the ratio so if you go up
with your d3 to 20 000
ius
then you need
200
micrograms of k2 all right number two
avoid those things that are triggering
your allergies like in environmental
allergies as in food allergies that's
really really important but what's
really interesting about allergies in
general is that you can get rid of
allergies by doing periodic prolonged
fasting yeah because you strengthen the
immune system when you do fasting
there's some great data on that i've
done videos on that but yeah so you
don't have to live with your allergies
all right number three chronic
infections
uh the best way to handle that
especially if it's like epstein-barr
virus or
some type of virus that's lodged in your
body
is to take regular vitamin d which is
good for the immune system as well as
regular vitamin c but make sure the
vitamin c is not synthetic use a whole
food form you can also do herbs that are
antibacterial as well because they don't
have the side effects like garlic thyme
oregano oil i've done videos on that
i'll put the links down below alright
for any gut issue don't forget about
zinc l carnosine a really good form of
zinc and for heart problems okay like in
heart attacks preventing heart attacks
things like that
one of the best vitamins is vitamin e
but not tocopherol you want to take
telcatrino's okay 300 milligrams
very very important because it's like 50
times stronger and it can actually clean
up the free radical damage and
inflammation in the heart
and
realize that you also need to at the
same time get rid of the cause of that
problem which is consuming too much
sugar okay you gotta go low carb to
really get rid of that oxidation that's
happening
but vitamin e can greatly reduce
the inflammation in the inside of your
arteries as well as the inflammation in
your liver all right number six the most
important thing
low carb in a minute of fasting if
you're new to my channel
click the link down below vital and
important action okay that's the most
important thing you can do all right
number seven you need to do intermittent
fasting and periodic prolonged fasting
that's going to drop inflammation also
take regular amounts of vitamin d
and turmeric is a very very good natural
compound to reduce inflammation just
make sure that the source of turmeric
is from a really good place recently i
found a farmer who grows the stuff in
his greenhouse and it's the best
turmeric i've ever found
he dries it out chops it up and i buy it
from him and i actually chew it and it
is like explodes in your mouth but it's
a really good source but there's a lot
of herbal things you can take for
inflammation
like
stinging nettle root another one of my
favorites all right number eight
anytime you have right-sided um
inflammation or pain don't forget purify
bile salts or tug-cut is is a type of
purified bile salts that you can take
but then you need to work more on the
gallbladder and of course your diet as
well all right number nine start
increasing your omega-3 fatty acids
which i talked about and decreasing your
omega-6 fatty acids and number 10 be
careful with the iron so i wouldn't
recommend cooking in iron skillets i
wouldn't recommend taking these
multivitamins
the real popular ones with a lot of iron
in them
not a good idea in fact i'm very
hesitant taking any vitamins with added
iron unless it's in the right form
but you'd be shocked to find out some of
the lead multivitamin minerals
really just have this like iron ore this
elemental iron that is like not the
right type for our bodies
and the other problem with iron is iron
is fortified in all the grain products
so in one video i did a while ago as i
showed people how you can take a magnet
okay a strong magnet and dump out like a
box of cereal um on a platform take the
magnet and it picks up
the cereal because of the added
iron the fortification of iron in those
wheat products
but of course if you've been watching my
channel you're not consuming grains so
you're totally safe all right so now
that you have a superior level of
understanding about inflammation
i'm going to show you a great technique
on how to get rid of pain okay
check it out it's right here